Hey guys,
Tim Ferriss here.
I'm going to show you how I went from
very grumpy baby to slightly happier baby
and for those of you don't
know what happy baby is,
it looks like this and
referred to a lot in yoga.
It's something like this and another
way to think of it would be like this,
this type of position, and I've always
had a lot of difficulty with it.
It's extremely important for a lot of
things, the highly specific acro yoga,
things like that,
which I'll show in a minute.
And then you have just general hip
health and there are many ways to improve
that position. I stalled for probably
a year and a half, two years,
huge, huge pain and it turned out a few
things were very helpful for me. Waited,
stretches, combined with
presses and a few other things.
So I'm going to show you the sequence
that I have found most helpful and it's
going to be within the context
of Acro Yoga. So Kipling,
this is a my friend Caitlin, Sag
Mueller at Kip Lynn, Kip, l. I n.
N on all the socials.
Let's do some bird presses first.
So this is a position of
acro yoga called bird.
And I'm going to be policing my feet
basically on her hipbones right here.
So the middle of my feet are gonna be
right here and you'll see as I go through
this what we're going to do this,
the safest way to get into it.
So we can do it with no hands if we
do it, no hands, it looks like that.
Okay. Generally if we come
down, we're going to use hands,
the Flyer, I'm the base flyer fingers
forward as a good way to remember it.
And we're just going to come up like that.
So very often I would do the presses
with the hands so that would look like
this.
Okay.
But I these days use it with no hands.
And when I do this,
I'm pointing with the toes slightly.
I'm bringing the knees down and I am
trying to keep my tailbone on the ground.
The temptation will be to roll up and I
want to try to keep this seated and then
I will pull down with my
hands towards the ground.
And if your feet starts slipping out,
you can just correct with the hands.
You can squeeze the hand to indicate
where you want to place the weight,
readjust the foot where you just the foot.
And then we continue.
And I'll typically do
six repetitions of this.
I'm only going to do two right now.
So we'd come down and you can kind of
play with the balance of feet pointing and
so on.
And then coming back up to 90
degrees and I'll do one more.
And you can see,
you can kind of play with positioning,
really trying to pull down into
grab your baby slash have UV.
So that's part one.
All right.
Now what I've found is that just
putting yourself into this position for
extended periods of time, it doesn't work
for me. So I will do six repetitions.
You noticed five or six repetitions into
Max depth just for a second or two and
then out.
And what I found is that there's a
compression on the lag when my legs are
straight. And I'll show you another
example of that and just a few minutes.
Then there's traction.
So Kimberly do you want to show just
the feet behind the hips? Traction.
So you can do this in as partners where
you turn the feet in and then she's just
leaning back on my feet,
which is giving me a nice,
I'm going to traction the hips.
So I will do this in between
many of these exercises.
Thank you Kaitlin.
And I'll also do that for my wrists.
So this is not limited to the hips.
I will get say a towel of some type and
I will pull on the fingers if I'm doing
a lot of handstand work or something like
that. So this is all transferable. Okay,
so we have wordpress is number one.
Number two,
I'm working on internal and external
rotation of the leg in both lights
independently.
So we're going to do a cartwheel into
side star and I'll also show you some
stuff that is not accurate dependent,
but so if we come up and then
we'll go onto the opposite side
here.
All right,
so I'm getting this compression on a
single leg and you'll notice that Kip Lynn
has effectively 90 degree angle
between her legs here. This, this foot,
the bottom foot is actually
very close to the ground.
Okay?
And
we'll do generally a five to six reps
on either side is what I typically do.
This part of the warm up. All right?
So then we're going to cartwheel out.
Now what we're gonna do is instead of
having a good amount of extra rotation and
we focused on internal rotation and a,
we will do that going from the bird
position, which you've already seen,
two of these slightly
different type of sides to her.
So from here
I'm going to coq one foot out and then
Katelyn is going to slide onto that foot
and you'll see how she
uses her arm support,
no,
this. Then we get this rotation and
this internal rotation on this leg.
Now when I come back,
watch how I bend my legs,
I'm going to push with the support leg
and catch with the other foot and we come
up.
Then internal rotation.
This one is very tough for a lot of women
and a lot of guys in particular guys
with stiff hips don't rotate worth a damn.
It's a very therapeutic exercise.
Also teaches you how to have soft feet
if you're doing more accurate yoga or
anything that includes some
of hamstring flexibility.
Okay, let's dispel it.
So we come down.
All right.
So I want to show a few things that are
not accurate dependent that I sometimes
do in between these exercises.
So one of them I'll come over.
Okay,
is this,
so this is a rad roller and uh,
the one of the guests on my podcast,
a Amelia Boone,
who is the world's most successful female
obstacle course racer taught me and as
did coach summer.
So Chris Sommer,
former national team coach for men's
gymnastics in the u s that people think of
hamstring flexibility. Oftentimes
the restrictions that are like, oh,
I can't touch my toes are related
to the lower legs and the feet.
So I will roll out my feet
like cell and I'll travel
with this rad roller.
This is not very exciting to watch,
but you'll get the idea.
So food is right in the middle here and
I'll generally do it very slowly and
then I'll caulk it out like so.
And then in and uh,
you can,
you can accelerate a lot of your
hamstring flexibility progress.
So I will do this on the feet also very
good for the forearms and you can roll
them on the floor when you're doing a lot
of handstand or straight or port. Okay,
a good idea.
I don't always do this,
but it's tuning gorge to the calves and
stretch the Achilles and the calves.
Before you do your hamstring work, it
was making a lot easier. All right,
now I'll show you a few things,
uh,
because I will often take a break before
the next one because I find it have
found it historically very difficult.
It's getting a lot easier. Uh,
other things that I will do is I'll focus
on back rotation also to get the mid
back and traps and lats engaged.
But this is a kind of a modified
like mark for Stagen type movement.
I think Eric Cressey also uses
something very similar. Uh,
I will get into this
type of lunge position.
What's very important is that my
hips are square. I'm not doing this,
I'm not doing this.
It's not a warrior post type of thing.
The toes are pointing straight ahead.
And then what I'll do is simply drop this
elbow flat to the ground and then come
up,
pinch this leg in and wrote good.
And then if that is easy, I'll just
inch the foot forward and do it again.
And as per usual,
I will do probably six of these,
right?
And that you would just
do it on the opposite side
and we're just going to kind of match
range for a second and then write out,
we're not staying for 30 seconds
or on staying for two minutes, uh,
that there are options for
that, but I don't do them as
part of this warmup. Okay.
And once we've done all that,
there is one last that I would recommend,
especially for guys. And this is just
a general warmup, uh, recommendation,
sort of just stretching this way,
stretching this way,
focusing on what we just did,
just rotation and an easy way to do that.
He's like this and this is,
I'm going to blank on his last name.
I Apologize Steve. I want to say Steve
Sydell but I don't think that's right.
Steve, who's basically the team
doc, also a competitor at parody.
So crossfit in Venice
should me this tweak,
which is not just in free
standing or free, uh,
squatting rotation, but using a
wall to ensure that you don't sheet,
that your hips don't translate.
So in this case, I have my hip,
my shoulder peg to the wall and I'm
just going to be crawling down and then
coming straight up. And I asked him,
well, if you have pain in your back,
had you know if you should
do the exercise or not.
And his answer was if it
feels better as you go after,
say five repetitions and your
range of motion has increased,
that means you do the
movement. Uh, so that is that.
And then the final move that I'll show
you is called a well one is a star press
and then you have a walk to star
and I'll show you what that is.
So I like to start with the negative.
What does that mean? Negative,
we have concentric and
then East centric movement.
So the concentric movement you
can see the Bicep is contracting,
it's getting shorter.
Then as you lower it's getting longer.
That's the East centric or negative.
So I start with negatives with
star and then go to walk ups and,
and we'll, we'll, I'll show
you exactly what that is.
So probably good to face this way
to show this.
All right, so the hand grip, for those of
you who might be wondering is like this,
this is the grip that we're using a sort
of two fingers on the wrist and then
the hands wrapped as so, and we're
trying to maintain a comfortable angle.
This is flat.
This is steep,
usually end up somewhere in between and
you'd just like dancing with a partner.
We've figured out so what
grip works for us. Okay.
All right,
so this is star and very often the hands
or the arms of the flyer and this case
Kipling are going to be
straight. They can be bent. Um,
we can do some crazy stuff like Freestar
which we don't have to do right now,
which is no hands. Uh, but the presses,
so the negative I mentioned just going
to lower like so and then all right,
back up. I'm going to do the
same on the opposite side.
Just like that. He notices this
very grumpy baby and then we come up
and then from here I would do that
probably two or three reps and other side.
And then we're just going to [inaudible]
walk down to that.
This is bad or straddle that. Then
we're going to do a walk up. All right,
so this will be pretty self explanatory,
just like so.
And you just do that
on both sides.
So I'm just
going to pop just for fun
and then I'll show you guys what a pop
is just for fun. Don't try this at home.
He need professional supervision.
Ready? One, two,
and then you can get that pet
and that. Ladies and gents, especially
if you're utilizing Acroyoga,
which I think is a great way
to improve hip health, uh,
for El basing when I was doing
that is how you can go over time,
but pretty quickly in my case,
from very grumpy baby, too happy.
Maybe if you enjoyed this video,
I have more to share all of the tools,
tactics, cool things that I'm finding.
Five bullet Friday. It is an exclusive
newsletter. It's completely free.
I sent it out every Friday.
Just has five bullet points with the
coolest was useful things that I found or
I'm revisiting that week.
And you can find it by clicking here.
Takes about five minutes to read.
Super Short, very actionable.
Five bullet Friday. Also
found@fourhourworkweek.com
forward slash Friday.